I'd love to start with where and when
did the idea of for Bardo first come to
you how long have you been thinking
about making this film
well good night everybody thank you for
being here
um basically the I think has to do a lot
with the an installation that I did in
2017 Carnegie Arena
and I think around that time five years
ago
I think that project I have the
privilege to interview a lot of 100 more
than 500 immigrants and I did this
um installation about these people
crossing the border and they open their
hearts their stories and things so I
think that immigration experience that I
have profound two years took us to
Manuel Lewis can I to do this
installation I think that has a huge
impact in me and as an immigrant that I
have been 21 years out of my country I
think it touched a lot of things and has
to do with the age that I'm coming so
it's like to clean the closet a little
bit and to revise the the the reason how
it's one one year that was originally at
the adventure became 20 years in in one
second and the consequences and the
things that you come into this very in
between State you know
so let's talk about the writing process
how did the two of you Nicholas work
together and how long did that process
take
it was like a 40-year therapy session
for me
no I mean
we know each other for for a long time
and we're friends and and and
I always say that every every project
that I kind of invited me to participate
was completely very different
the starting point was very different
and very particular and you you sort of
have to learn how to write that
screenplay while you're writing it
sometimes you get to page 60 of the
first draft and you start to realize
what's what's the thing that you're
supposed to write you know a little bit
but basically we spend a lot of time
together and and this was a very
personal project so so I think that that
was the key those
two weeks at the beginning that we spent
together and finding
what the what the film was and and and
and how those experiences were going to
translate into the what the film is
and I don't think this film Works
without the right lead actor to take on
this role it's such a demanding
performance and you do it so well uh
Daniel I'm curious what was the first
meeting with Alejandro like how did you
how did he describe this film to you at
that point the first meeting was he was
looking for an actor and I think he
couldn't find it
so I was like the last choice
am I wrong
the cheapest
yeah
so but it was funny because he never did
a proper casting
he would only took we had a dinner and
we talked for four or five hours we
drunk a lot of mezcal a lot
and he was interviewing me about my life
the moment I was living now
and
he was trying to find if the if me I was
like the character he was looking no
and uh yeah it's very very I like always
to to speak about uh I I told him about
a guided meditation I did three weeks
before and I was telling him the images
I had and everything and then he was
like wow it seems like you already read
the script
that was one of so many magical
coincidences
that we had and then we are still having
and that was it so he said he's the guy
what made him the guy for you
I think you know we we are from the same
generation
Mexicans we live in the same city uh he
is the last child of uh six siblings I'm
the last child till five and we share
all these country at the same time we
have in 30 years married both we have
two kids basically the same age
we are in a kind of a
Journey an interior journey I will say
very similar of what we are looking for
what is priority what we are you know
things and I think that that the
interior life I think that's what really
unite us you know so I found that I know
the skills of Daniel which is the best
actor in Mexico so I didn't have any
doubt about his actual skills but for me
what's more more important for not only
for him but every cast member
I I was interested that
just putting the camera there I know
that the energy the frequency like when
you sit with somebody that you connect
or not I knew that when I connected was
that character that make my life easy
and that was very beautiful because I
think then funny if each of the
characters and the actor and the
actresses all of them there are stories
were really similar to the situation of
the characters which was very surprising
for me so I think it's a intuition that
I guide me you know
so Anna Martine Nikolai can you tell me
when you first either heard from
Alejandro or saw the script what you
anticipated to be the most difficult
part of your jobs on this one
so the the first time that I I they sent
me this group then Alejandro and I had a
conversation
um
this script for me I mean it was it was
really challenging it's a script that
that has this
sort of crows roads you know that take
you to to Two Worlds of
reality and dreams and and he has this
um sort of crazy turnarounds you know
that that made us all the team to be
very demanding and in terms of
creativity and Imagination to create
these characters and I remember the
first time that we talked Alejandro
mentioned that when he was imagining
this film and writing the film he
thought it about it in black and white
and
then obviously he said that he he didn't
want to do that and and because it's not
just only the
see various Journey it's also a journey
it's it's Mexico and it's a country that
it's full of color and how we were gonna
Embrace that country to tell this this
story and we all came to a conclusion
that the the journey was going to be
tell through color and and that's why we
chose to to give a certain color to each
of the characters the main characters
and
um and not just that like it was so
complex that we didn't want to situate
the film in in a certain time I mean
it's a story of a man and the the
memories and as they're saying they're
about a 59 year old man that has all
this memory so we have to also mix
certain periods in the costumes to give
this to the expectator to not really
feel in any particular time so we use
peer the garments from all over and and
in a very subtle way and I mean for me
it was really a pleasure working with
with Alejandro
uh he's he's one of the directors that
really LED all of us to collaborate in
the
in the process of the film and I'm very
grateful
thank you
hello for the two of you what did you
anticipate to be most difficult about
bringing the stuff Alejandro himself
always no but you know as you know I've
been blessed by knowing Alejandro since
we're kids nearly 40 years ago almost so
it's like a very old long marriage in a
way and
um I had a opportunity of reading the
script before the pandemia no and uh
I was you know in in my apartment
reading in the sofa I was saying well
this guy has some balls because it's so
you know so brave whatever is placed
there it's I'm an openness
of so many things I'm very much related
I come from the same city almost same
area of the city and same age so a lot
of things sorry in a way very similar
and coming from the background doing
previous films with him
but then
thank God for that we found that a fresh
look was needed very much needed in
terms of you know sound Concepts and and
that's where Nico came I had a
opportunity of meeting Nico some years
ago when we were doing
yeah
so for me it was very different because
uh of course
was for me a good you know kind of so
when when uh I've been in touch to work
with with him I was uh I didn't I mean
it was a dream you know and I remember
the first because I started to work on
the funeral was in Paris
so we were organizing organizing
sessions
where he was describing all the
possibilities of the film you know so
normally some directors they they close
things you know I want that I want and
it was the opposing you know it was an
invitation to explore and to to try to
to to go to uh kind of
labyrinthic process and try to to uh in
a very open way try very different style
you know combine different ideas so so
it was a fantastic journey and and and
so for me it's a
immense I mean like it's it's a
life-changing uh experience so yeah it's
it
uh we're almost out of time so I do want
to wrap
you Alejandro you know this film does
grapple and explore identity and I'm
curious if making this shifted anything
in your own identity for you once it was
complete
I think like the character says my
identity is no identity I think is is I
don't know how how many of you have left
your country for so many years and
things but you realize I think what I
realized there is no conclusions and
it's not like a bad thing or a sorry
thing is that it's just to embrace
the reality that
once once you do not stay in only one
place and you go into this adventure and
take the opportunity which has been
great in so many levels to be in this
country but at the same time there's no
matter what there's contradictions and
you know paradoxes and challenges and
things and then you find yourself again
in this space that you are maybe too
much you know to in Mexico you know they
consider me not now as I was or what
they expect from me and here I will not
belong and obviously your child's grow
and your adolescent things and you find
yourself a little bit floating like a
tree without roots kind of floating
um I think what I have found is that I
have to surrender to that and allow that
to be the condition
in order for me to happily and
enthusiastically embrace the fact that I
am not this or that but I'm just
becoming all the time
and I'm embracing that uncertainty in a
good way because that allowed me the
space to transform to grow to see things
detach and with perspective which which
I think is a great thing and I found
finally that the only thing that I can
call a nation or my identity is my
family
my family is my nation and that's where
I have found it like that that is
unconditional and that they don't ask me
for passports so that's what I have
found
well thank you all for giving us a
little view thank you thank you thank
you everybody thank you